after days of speculation and no doubt
weeks of planning U.S President Joe
Biden arrived in the Ukrainian Capital
cave nearly a year to the day that
Russia invaded
the White House said there had been
basic communication with Moscow just
before the visit to ensure what it
called the conflictation and to avoid a
miscalculation that could lead to open
conflict between the two nuclear powers
an air raid siren wailed across the city
as the two men walked near Saint
Michael's Cathedral not uncommon when
world leaders have visited Kiev since
the War Began the U.S president
described the night of the invasion when
he called the Ukrainian leader
he admitted he had feared Russia could
quickly take control of all of Ukraine
that dark night
one year ago
the world was literally at the time
bracing for the fall of cave
seems like a lot longer ago than a year
but think back to that year
perhaps even the end of Ukraine
you know one year later
key stands
and Ukraine stands
democracy stands
the American stands with you and the
world stands with you
Biden announced an additional half a
billion dollars in usas but there was no
mention of new Advanced Weaponry such as
long-range missiles the zelinski says
his forces need the Ukrainian president
stressed again there will be no peace
until Ukraine liberates all its
territory a promise that is among many
military analysts and some of Ukraine's
allies increasingly unrealistic as the
vast cost of this war and its Global
effects continues to grow
it was the conversation that indeed
brings closer our joint victory in this
war we can and we must ensure that 2023
becomes the year of Victory I want to
underline that this unprovoked and
criminal Russian war against Ukraine and
then tied Democratic world must end with
the liberation of Ukrainian land from
Russian occupation
and with solid guarantees of long-term
security for our country Europe and the
entire world
U.S President's first visit to Ukraine
almost exactly a year since Russia's
invasion is rich in symbolism and a
clear message to Moscow for Biden
zielinski and many of Ukraine's backers
maintaining unified support comes at a
vital time before an expected
intensification of fighting
in a so-called spring offensive Charles
Stratford Al Jazeera Kiev